We've already brought you a sensational set
of fan theories that could change how you
view your favorite movies, and now we're back
for the sequel!
Due to popular demand, we've brought you five
more crazy-but-kinda-plausible movie theories.
This time, they’re picked by you, straight
from the YouTube comments of our last film
theories video.
The Shining is Kubrick's apology for staging
the Lunar Landing
Break out the tin foil hats for this one.
In 1969, the United States sent some guys
to the moon.
It was a pretty big deal, and it was broadcast
on TV, live, around the world.
The whole thing was a feat of technology and
science the likes of which the world had never
seen.
Or was it?
A certain group of people believe that it
never happened, and that director Stanley
Kubrick staged the whole thing using cinema
magic.
And all of this hinges upon The Shining, and
young Danny Torrance's discovery of Room 237—supposedly
the most evil and heavily haunted room in
the Overlook Hotel.
At one point, Danny is seen playing with his
toys in a hallway with a unique carpet design,
not seen anywhere else in the Overlook.
According to the theory, this pattern reflects
the shape of an aerial view of a NASA shuttle
launch site.
Danny then rises to his feet, symbolizing
the Apollo 11 rocket on his sweater lifting
off.
He proceeds to Room 237, which was originally
Room 217 in the original Stephen King novel.
Why the change?
During the time of the movie's filming, the
Earth was believed to be approximately 237,000
miles from the moon.
This distance regularly fluctuates due to
orbit and actually averages out to 238,855
miles, but who cares?
It's a 1980 horror movie.
There's also a scene showing Danny and his
mother watching a TV that is visibly not hooked
into anything.
Allegedly, this illustrates that what people
watched on the television during Armstrong's
famous leap was all fake.
When Danny's father, Jack Torrance, investigates
Room 237 after Danny is spooked, he finds
a beautiful naked woman and embraces her.
To Jack's dismay, the woman transforms into
a decaying older woman.
Is Kubrick admitting that he was happy to
take a well-paying job to stage the lunar
landing until he realized what a deceptive
thing it really was?
Or...maybe people just need to get out more.
There's an entire documentary dedicated to
breaking down a lot of Kubrick's subliminal
messages hidden throughout The Shining.
The documentary's name?
Room 237.
Signs was about demons
Remember the whole alien invasion thing that
made up most of the plot of Signs?
Well, what if they weren't really aliens?
What if they were demons?
According to a theory first published on Reddit,
it could be the case.
First, the "alien invasion" results in hundreds
of thousands of people fleeing to temples,
churches, and other religious buildings for
safety.
Are these proper shelters, or a safe place
to hide with demons roaming around?
Second, we barely see any alien technology,
except for a few lights in the sky.
Third, if these "aliens" can travel through
space, it stands to reason they'd be smart
enough to realize they were allergic to water.
Especially on a planet whose surface is covered
with it.
The alien… we mean demon at the end of the
movie isn't hurt by H2O alone, but because
the water is blessed.
Throughout the movie, Mel Gibson's daughter
would regularly get a full glass of water,
sip it, put it down, and get a new glass.
Half-full glasses litter the house.
When Gibson speaks of the day she was born,
he describes her birth as holy, even saying
that everyone who saw her that day thought
she was an angel.
This divine description transfers to her blessing
every half-filled cup left throughout the
house, effectively leaving holy water all
over the place.
It's not like the rest of the world chased
off an alien invasion with a bunch of Super
Soakers.
Mad Max is Death
Redditor EldarCorsair posted an awesome breakdown
of Mad Max: Fury Road, which argues that each
of the three major warlords in the movie represent
one of the Horsemen of the Apocalypse.
Warlord Immortan Joe is Pestilence.
His people are sick due to the nuclear fallout
throughout the land.
Joe rules the population by offering them
small amounts of water, as if he has the key
to healing them.
The second Horseman, War, would be another
warlord, the Bullet Farmer.
You know, the guy firing wildly into the dark
when the tanker was stuck in the mud.
The third Horseman, Famine, would be the warlord
known as the People Eater, since he's huge
and represents the gluttony of the rich.
These guys trade food, drink, and weaponry
among one another in order to ensure their
rule on this apocalyptic wasteland.
And the fourth Horseman, Death?
That's Max.
Think about it: Max brings death wherever
he goes across the wasteland, and he's haunted
by the deaths of everyone he wasn't able to
save.
In his first scene, he brings death to a lizard-like
creature by eating it.
Death was on Furiosa's side, and her mission
was ultimately a success.
Remember when Max walks off into the darkness
to take on the Bullet Farmer's heavily armed
vehicle?
He destroys the whole thing by himself off-screen,
kills all the men on board, and hauls away
all their stuff.
You don't even see what happens, you just
assume that Max killed them all, like he always
does.
It proves Max/Death is a constant, inexorable
force of nature.
Jar Jar Binks is a Sith Lord
Out of all the movie theories mentioned in
response to our previous video, Darth Jar
Jar was the most frequently requested by far.
As crazy as it sounds, lots of people believe
that the bumbling Gungan we met on Naboo back
in The Phantom Menace is actually the most
powerful Sith Lord in the universe.
Think about this: young Anakin Skywalker was
able to escape just about every event unscathed
due to his natural aptitude for the Force.
Jar Jar was also unharmed during the battle
between the Gungans and the Trade Federation.
Don't let his goofy demeanor trick you.
Remember, Yoda was originally introduced as
just a silly, swamp-dwelling creature on Dagobah
before turning out to be an old Jedi Master.
Jar Jar can also be seen using a "wave motion"
that usually accompanies the Jedi mind trick
during various parts of Episode I when speaking
to important characters.
He apparently uses this while persuading the
entire Senate to grant full control and emergency
power to Supreme Chancellor Palpatine...and
it works.
This action puts Palpatine in the perfect
position to control everything and rise to
power as Emperor.
Even when Qui-Gon Jinn mentions using the
Force to guide him underneath the waters of
Naboo, Jar Jar scoffs at the concept.
Don't forget, Palpatine and Jar Jar Binks
are both from Naboo and they could have met
each other decades earlier.
At Qui-Gon's funeral at the end of The Phantom
Menace, Jar Jar is standing right beside Palpatine,
which starts a recurring theme of them being
seen together.
In the beginning of Episode III, you can see
Jar Jar and Palpatine walking close to one
another.
Binks also senses Anakin and Obi-Wan's arrival
at the beginning of Episode II.
He approaches the elevator for no reason and
doesn't attempt to open the door.
He just waits a second or two, knowing that
they are coming, but still acts surprised
to see them once the door opens in order to
maintain his cover.
Maybe Jar Jar's almost too-obvious clumsiness
wasn't why he was banned from the underwater
Gungan city, and why they treated him like
a threat when he arrived.
Maybe Supreme Leader Snoke is a front and
Jar Jar Binks still continues to pull the
strings of the Dark Side.
And now, for one more long-time theory that
was actually proven to be true...
Deckard is a Replicant
Ridley Scott's 1982 sci-fi neo-noir classic
Blade Runner is all about androids.
These androids, also known as replicants,
look and think like humans, and possess self-awareness.
All that, and they're mainly used for dangerous
grunt work on off-planet colonies.
Some of them try to abandon their hazardous
work and hide on Earth.
These escapees are tracked by Blade Runners,
a group of special police operatives who find
and execute errant replicants.
Blade Runner Rick Deckard, played by Harrison
Ford, is responsible for eliminating a group
of rogue replicants.
It’s a quest that leaves him questioning
his duties as he struggles with the idea that
many of these replicants just want to live.
One replicant he meets during his investigation
even believes she is actually human.
The idea that Deckard himself is a replicant
has been debated for years.
Harrison Ford claims that he was playing a
human character.
According to BBC News, Ford mentioned that
he and the director had talks about Deckard
being a replicant, and that they both agreed
he was human during filming.
But in subsequent interviews over the years,
Ridley Scott has said otherwise:
"He's a replicant."
Perhaps Scott lied to Ford to make his performance
much more convincing.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know if there
are any more fan theories you’d like to
see explored...